I have an announcement to make I've been
asked to announce that Sylvester
Stallone has suggested that the
oscar-winning picture of this year be
determined by a 10-round bout in the
parking lot he didn't really say that
it's what's written out there while we
polled the other nominees we welcome
back and Margaret
how important is the musical score to a
motion picture well
just imagine vertigo without the
haunting score behind the face of Kim
Novak imagine Laura without the song of
the same name
try to imagine psycho without the
riveting shriek the driving impact of an
orchestra and full fire the ghost of
Rebecca would not return if it weren't
for the recall given us by the music now
tonight's nominees for music score
adaptation Bound for Glory adapted by
Leonard Rosalyn Bugsy Malone song score
and it's adaptation by Paul Williams a
star is born
adapted by Roger Kelly bomb for glory
adapted by Leonard Rosamund
which is really almost underwater minor
absurdity because I do write original
music - I'm really tremendously
gratified to receive this award for the
second consecutive year and I'd like to
make more than just ritual thanks
I'd like to of course thank my dear wife
Lynne for the atmosphere of tranquillity
that she provided so that I could do my
best work on this project I'd like to
thank my closest and dearest friend Bob
Brad Nitz for bringing my work and my
interest in this project to the
attention of producer Bob bloom off and
I thank Bob bloom off and our Leventhal
producers of this film for their
interest in my work and of course for
allowing me to work with the master
director Hal Ashby whom I am proud to
call my friend as a great human being
and as a great direction I thank you
very much